this morning we're talking baby formula
as some kinds of baby formula is getting
harder to find all across the country
leaving parents scrambling for
alternatives baby formula counted for
more than four billion dollars in sales
in 2021 that's up four and a half
percent from 2020 and our consumer
investigative correspondent anna werner
has been talking to truly frustrated
parents
he's a little happy boy
san francisco residents irene and mario
on hook are the parents of marlow a 10
month old boy
his mom can't breastfeed so from birth
they've fed him a liquid infant formula
from simelac but now say it's in short
supply we noticed it being difficult to
find maybe a couple months ago two three
months ago and then just recently we
can't find it we've tried all the local
targets we checked costco's costs go
online walgreens longs can't find it
anywhere
her husband even drove an hour away no
luck so the couple switched to the
powdered version of the formula but say
marlow sometimes spits it up or won't
finish it it just worrisome a little bit
for us because we want to just make sure
he's getting all the calories he needs
and all the nutrition he needs from the
formula because he's not here yet
many parents around the country are
reporting the same thing bare shelves or
very low stocks of baby formula from new
york to washington state the infant
nutrition council of america confirms
reports of challenges across supply
chains it's been worsening a little bit
in the last three four weeks if you can
sell more kk duvet with retail research
firm iri says for major brands of baby
formula powder the average national in
stock rate before the pandemic was 95
percent but his firm found as of last
week rates of availability across 10
national retailers ranged from 98
percent to as low as 75 percent powdered
formula was less available in some
cities including seattle wichita kansas
and tucson
why are there shortages on infant
formula some of the shortages are
related to procuring the raw materials
some of it in production some of it is
in packaging and then labor shortages in
the factory in transportation
empty shelves are what mom tiffany
mannin says she's been finding north of
orlando florida no matter where we
looked it was sold out her 10 week old
son corbin was born six weeks premature
she says doctors instructed her to feed
him a liquid enfamil product so he'd
gain weight the company helped by
sending her free cases of the product
but now she says local stores are out of
the liquid and powder versions
are you worried
i am worried again it comes to our minds
of once we do run out of this formula
what's going to happen if they're sold
out enfamil's maker reckett told us they
have ample supply of their formula
products but said u.s baby formula
industry-wide sales are up 18 percent
which is more than double birth rates
the company says in response it's
ramping up production and is currently
shipping 50 percent more product to
address issues as fast as possible the
manufacturer of similac products abbott
did not respond to our questions about
supplies and availability neither did
nestle which makes gerber products
tiffany mannin says she worries with
parents like her on the hunt for
supplies some may choose to hoard
formula leaving her to go without this
is my child how am i supposed to feed my
child if he does not have what he needs
to be fed because people are hoarding it
or this product shortage
we reached out to major retail outlets
most of them told us they are working
with their suppliers to cover customer
demand abbott referred us to the infant
nutrition council now that group says
that its manufacturers too are working
to ensure availability that analyst we
spoke to tony is hoping that things will
loosen up here in terms of supplies of
formula in about four to six weeks so
hopefully that's a good
note for parents
jeez i mean you can hope so formula is
food it's hard to imagine a more
critical issue for parents particularly
parents of babies under six months of
age who can't get anything else anna
thank you very much we know you'll stay
on top of it